en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina
torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos en esta ocasión iniciamos
hablando de un estudio del impidió al
college de londres que expone que las
vacunas contra el kobe 19 evitaron
alrededor de 20 millones de muertes a
nivel global
observamos que la mayoría de las muertes
se evitaron en los países de ingresos
altos y medios altos y eso se debe en
gran parte a su acceso a vacunas de rn m
más eficaces como la vacuna de países y
modernas pero también al hecho de que
pudieron lograr resultados muy altos en
los niveles de cobertura de vacunas
antes de relajar las intervenciones no
farmacéuticas y permitir que aumentara
la transmisión otra cifra destacada del
estudio es que se podrían haber evitado
otras casi 600.000 muertes si se hubiera
cumplido el objetivo de la organización
mundial de la salud de vacunar al 40 por
ciento de la población en todos los
países para finales de 2021 el texto
explica que la mayoría de los
fallecimientos se produjeron en áfrica y
el mediterráneo oriental y añade que si
los países de bajos eso se hubieran
podido alcanzar la meta una de cada
cinco muertes se habría evitado
no sólo se trata de un compartir más
equitativo de vacunas alrededor del
mundo y de no retener las en los países
más ricos aunque fue parte del problema
particularmente en las primeras etapas
también pasó que los países que
recibieron eventualmente las vacunas no
estaban bien equipados para proveerlas a
la gente
tipo am and end y the people las
personas no pudieron acceder a un buen
tipo de información para impulsarlas a
venir y buscar esas vacunas estamos
acostumbrados a asumir que las
propagandas antivacunas son una
peculiaridad y occidente
no es el equipo que realizó la
investigación destaca los buenos
resultados del programa de reparto de
vacunas kóvacs que previno 75 millones
de decesos no obstante expertos alertan
que la pandemia de con 19 expuso una
grave falta de infraestructura en los
países con más bajos ingresos requerida
para la distribución de estas
inyecciones por lo que creen que otro
evento similar tendría los mismos
problemas que no permitieron una mejor
entrega de estos fármacos
vamos ahora a hablar de robótica
ingenieros de la escuela james watt de
la universidad de glasgow desarrollaron
un tipo de piel electrónica que puede
sentir dolor y puede recordar cómo se
siente en diferentes tipos de contacto
la piel está equipada con transistores
sinápticos que imitan la capacidad del
cerebro para aprender el material fue
probado en un brazo robótico
puntualmente en una mano en principio no
hubo respuesta al ser pinchada pero
luego aprendió a responder
apropiadamente
a
los transistores sinápticos impresos que
tenemos son capaces de aprender en un
periodo de tiempo y ese proceso desde
los estás así que contrario a otras
versiones de piel tienes un periodo de
aprendizaje corto y otro más largo
y si lo unes con modalidades sensoriales
con una función sensorial es probable
que ciertas interacciones sean mucho más
efectivas que las que conocemos hoy en
día
para construir la piel electrónica
similar a la humana los investigadores
imprimieron una cuadrícula de 168
transistores sinápticos hecha de nano
hilos de óxido de zinc directamente
sobre una superficie de plástico
flexible
luego conectaron esa red con el sensor
de la piel en la palma del robot cuando
el sensor recibe estímulos registra un
cambio en la resistencia eléctrica
cualquier cambio corresponde a un ligero
toque una presión mayor crea un cambio
mayor en la resistencia así imita el
trabajo de las neuronas sensoriales en
el cuerpo humano
de los robots pasamos a hablar de
hologramas por primera vez en la
historia estudiantes de medicina van a
poder practicar procedimientos con
pacientes solo gráficos se trata de una
nueva dinámica que será implementada por
los hospitales de la universidad de
cambridge y estará disponible a partir
de 2023 lo que les permitiría a los
estudiantes aprender en escenarios
altamente realistas la tecnología se
diferencia de la realidad virtual porque
incluye elementos virtuales en el
ambiente real es lo que se conoce como
realidad mixta
la simulación nos permite es que
nuestros estudiantes estén en un
ambiente seguro y se sientan seguros of
course
es algo que queremos hacer con pacientes
reales así que el ambiente de simulación
permite a los estudiantes tomar esos
siguientes pasos en su aprendizaje sobre
tienen un ambiente muy real para
practicar sus habilidades y técnicas lo
que necesitarán para encontrarse con
pacientes de verdad
[Música]
la tecnología también ayudará a expandir
los ejercicios de entrenamiento con
simulación de alta calidad a los
hospitales y universidades que no puedan
pagar otras opciones el software aún
está en etapa de desarrollo pero el
grupo piloto lleva probando este
programa casi cinco meses y nuevas
herramientas vendrán en próximas
versiones
y finalizamos en el volcán etna en
italia donde el centro aeroespacial
alemán está probando robots controlados
a distancia para simular situaciones que
los astronautas van a encontrar en
futuros viajes lunares o en la
exploración de marte los científicos
explican que la luna y el monte etna
tienen superficies y condiciones
similares por lo que se pueden imitar la
geología y las condiciones de una misión
real a la luna uno de los requisitos
para los robots es manipular objetos es
decir recolectar muestras y examinarlas
en el sitio para intercambiar datos que
hayan adquirido y luego comunicarse con
el centro de control
así finalizamos este espacio a ustedes
gracias por su sintonía continúen con
nosotros en france 24 y france24
puntocom
[Música]